the bigger problem on the ground at the
moment because it is bursting forth and
we don't know where the F these people
are is that in the last three years
about six million people have come into
the United States and there is no border
we can pretend that there is but there
is not the Democrats have decided to
have Sanctuary states and cities crime
is ramp in fenel all over the place
people know that these cities are not as
safe as they used to be uh and by the
way and we'll we'll show you evidence of
this this was not the samee Democrat
position even of 15 years ago uh but
first let's show you more from the US
Border in Arizona this past
weekend literally looks like World War Z
did you see World War Z with Brad Pit
that's what it looked like like when the
zombies were taken over again all men
that appeared to be in their 20s and 30s
fighting age where are the women where
are the old women etc etc uh but of
course they're not just coming by land
they're also coming by sea uh here is a
migrant boat do I have to call them
migrants here is a boat full of people
who we don't know who the f they are
showing up on the coast of La Hoya
California that's San Diego for those of
you playing along at
home
it is I I wasn't sure what we
doing my life guards aren't going to do
[Music]
they're illegal
aliens they're all dressed in black too
like wouldn't you dress a little
differently so you don't automatically
look like the bad guy the the person
breaking into the country like if this
was Game of Thrones and a boat showed up
just randomly on someone's Shore you
Slaughter these people they cannot come
but we are just letting these people
come in we don't know who they are where
they're going etc etc it is it is there
is a full on Invasion happening in the
United States and you know for those of
you that have been watching this show
for years if you've been getting your
news online for years you need only go
back seven eight years this is exactly
the videos you're seeing both showing up
to to beaches uh people rampaging
through the borders this is exactly what
was happening in Europe seven eight
years ago exactly what was happening and
do you think that they're so thrilled
about it now when they have the Jihad
rallies in London and when Germany is
having massive right-wing protests
because people are sick of all of the
ille illegal immigration like we are
just repeating the same on our
Shores